Everyone needs sleep, but for many birds,
by necessity this has to happen while perched
on a branch or other place that must be gripped.
Anyone who has ever fallen asleep reading
and found her book on the floor knows how
difficult it can be to hold onto something
while snoozing.
So how do perching birds do it?
Powered by tendons, the feet of grasping birds
(think perching birds and raptors) have a
pair of them in the back, flexor digitorum
longus and flexor halluciss longus, which
are connected to deep flexor muscles in the
leg.
The digitorum branches and works the three
toes in the front, while the hallucis works
the back toe, known as the hallux.
Both stretch over the ankle, and when the
bird lands and the ankle bends, this forces
both tendons to automatically pull, thus clenching
the toes closed.
As long as the ankle is bent, the tendons
and toes are locked into place.
For perching birds, this results in a dependable
grip that lasts even when sleeping.
Raptors use this automatic response for another
purpose as well – grasping prey.
As the raptor approaches its victim, its legs
are outstretched, but when it lands, its ankles
bend, pulling the tendons and closing the
toes – resulting in a firm grip on its dinner.
Even in flight, as long as the bird’s legs
are bent, the tendons and toes remain locked
on the prey.
Not all birds have this feature, and for those
forced to sleep on the ground, some have developed
another adaptation to slumber safely – sleeping
with one eye open.
Known as unihemispheric slow-wave sleep, some
birds, like mallard ducks, can keep half of
their brain (and its corresponding eye) alert
while allowing the other half to take a break.
With the mallards, they often rest in a row,
with the ducks on the ends closing the eye
next to their neighbors, but keeping the eye
facing potential danger open.
Like the mallard ducks, dolphins and whales
often sleep with one eye open in order to
avoid being eaten by sharks.
The ability to stay partially conscious also
allows them to continue to get air while sleeping.
How dolphins handle this is to put one half
of their brain to sleep, while the other half
is still conscious and functioning.
They then alternate which side is sleeping
periodically.
They stay in this state for approximately
eight hours a day.
Doing this allows them to be conscious enough
to control their breathing and periodically
swim to the surface and get air, while still
giving their brain the rest it needs.